joining us here on the mercedes-benz
vans phone like chris you ready for this
one i mean is he your favorite is he he
is he is my favorite player not named
michael jordan i mean i grew up in the
age where like every kid loves michael
jordan but so then he's being from the
northeast paul pierce is my guy i love
this guy do you i mean
i i don't want to make it awkward no
if he was here be even more awkward well
you'd want to hug from him right yeah
and i would have brought in my 08 finals
and jersey to i'd be where you know it
would be a big thing okay he would be me
like yesterday when stone cold was here
that would be well geez oh here we go
okay so let's get him right here uh on
the rich eisen show on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line uh a basketball hall of
famer one of the all-time greats from
the boston celtics courtesy of
draftkings joining us here is paul
pierce how you doing paul
yo what's up hey i'm on the great rich
eisen show i can't believe it what do
you mean you can't believe it what are
you talking about calling now finally
after all these years i'm on
paul you you you've had an open
invitation that you just clearly i guess
didn't know about come on now
come on now this is great
how's everybody
we're good chris do you want to say
hello to parker
on behalf of the celtic nation just
thank you for your
years and years of greatness the title
and 08 and everything uh we appreciate
you now and forever
hey hey did y'all see the the retirement
wasn't it great we got the big three
back together it was amazing we talked
about that earlier in the week and i
mean the amount of tissues i had to wipe
my face from the tears like kevin
garnett telling the crowd that he
he f's with you guys
it was amazing and just like big baby
during the game getting kicked out of
his seat because he wasn't he was in the
wrong seat like everything eddie house
like everybody being there was so
incredible and the fact that ray showed
up and you guys are you know we're all
good now it's it's just it's fantastic
no that was awesome i loved it i got
paul pierce here back on the rich eisen
show paul pierce courtesy of draftkings
here on the mercedes-benz vans phone
line let's get let's get into the uh the
garnet retirement ceremony as you
mentioned just moments ago big three
back together uh what was that like for
you to see paul
naw that was awesome man it was just
like you know everybody knew we had our
little feud going for so long and the
crazy thing is we
we
we always gonna be a brotherhood and you
know for for a rae
to show up the kg's retirement was
everything you know that i think you
know for people who didn't know we had a
chance to talk during the 75th
anniversary during all-star weekend but
for the celtic fans on the celtics in
the boston garden to see it up close and
personal was even more special and uh we
needed that i got to be honest with you
the fact that this happened and now you
know you're saying that that the 75th
you know anniversary at the all-star
game helped lead to it i'm kind of
surprised because the video that went
viral was uh ray getting dapped up by
lebron and kg having none of it to the
point where even lebron might have
snapped to attention over all of that
i'm sure you saw that video right yeah
was that was you know people were just
reading too much in there because we was
in the back laughing and joking before
all of that
huh no that everybody took that out of
context i'm telling you how you laughed
that next day when people were talking
about it well how much did you have to
do with uh bringing both uh both of
these guys together
paul how much were you broken um
you know what i'm friends with both of
them and i kind of call myself like the
glue and i just you know i had to make
that happen so when we were in the back
i was like come on man this is over with
everybody take a picture about the
chocolate we had two we didn't have too
many good times with our families and
stuff for it to come to this you know
and it's been blown over as we all say
time heals uh all womb and so you know
it's been enough time for us to just you
know squash it and just like look man we
had too many good times that outweighed
a bad time so
it's time for us to do this so there was
no groundwork laid before the all-star
game it was just the two
we went to the all-star game
you know i just kind of brought ray over
to where ticket was at
and then i was like come on y'all we
about to take this picture we bout to
squash it and then you know after the
seven we took the picture
uh during the all-star weekend on the
75th anniversary team
i call ray like look you gotta come to
the kg ceremony you know i don't know if
he was planning on doing but i was like
look you got to come i think it'll be
epic you know i think we need to do it
all right there in the guard let
everybody know that you know we still
the big three boston's big three
yeah but but i mean he had to also
know because he he's been on the record
of saying
that the snubs that he's received from
kevin really cut deep and he didn't want
to feel that way again so did you then
have to call kevin and say hey he's
coming
you know you're cool right did you have
to just check one last check in with kg
i did not know i did not tell kevin that
he was coming huh
i didn't i wanted that to be that was
going to be the big surprise
that's quite the dice roll paul i got to
be honest with you
but we made up during the all-star
weekend so you know this was like
icing on the cake once we got to the
kg's retirement
so then uh did you did you so you okay
so there's no there was no exhale when
you saw that kevin was all
cool with it right like you that's what
you expected is what you're saying paul
yeah i expected i mean because me and
kevin talked about it a lot you know
that's my boy we live down the street
from each other i was like man we gotta
we just gotta it's not letting it just
and i just popped up on him i was like
we talked about this a long time
um for a long time
yeah we're not something that just came
up because we was in the same room
together i was like man look you know kg
as you all know kg wrote a book he got
his own podcast and i was like you know
what it'll be dope dude if you had ray
on it and he was like yeah i would have
ray on it you know and it was just kind
of like
you know warming them up to it and then
you know when we saw it when we saw ray
it was like man come on it's about that
time you know so this is not something
that just oh let me throw this on you
kevin because you gotta you can't just
throw nothing on kg
and paul too nobody really knew what was
happening because rich said it was the
video that we saw of the side eye and
then you po and then you posted the
picture of the three of you on instagram
the next day and it was just like wait a
second is everything cool now like just
me and all the fans were just going nuts
yeah i had to post that because the
narrative you know when people look at
that video they create their own
narrative of what happened but like
people don't know he was in the back he
he and haha before all of that i just
think you know they just caught a kg
just breathing hard or looking up or
whatever
he already we hadn't already chopped it
up in the back and ray probably haven't
even spoke to lebron the whole time
until he went out there
you know what i'm saying so it's like
okay we had our moment with ray now ray
want to have his moment lebron because
as you know he won championships with
both of us
paul pierce here on the rich eisen show
courtesy of draftkings what was it who
did you meet on the 75th anniversary
team and you're like oh gosh this is the
coolest thing ever what was that moment
for you paul man that moment was likely
oh man
jerry west kareem
uh oh my god it was just magic
it's crazy i'm saying old lakers too i
mean but i grew up a maker fan
right i mean it just it gotta be like so
cool for the kid in you right i mean
that's the stuff you dream of oh that's
the stuff you know it's so crazy just
being back there and me looking
wide-eyed like a little kid in the candy
store
i had to like really like catch myself
like
i'm i'm in here like i'm a part of this
you know but i was like a fan for i was
a fan for the most part
but then i had to keep catching myself
when we took the picture and i looked to
my left and you see
magic and iverson and lebron and you
know the
jerry west and kareem it's like wow this
was unreal it's like you're never going
to get a room like that ever again
you know what i'm saying of course it
was just like real that's amazing paul
pierce here on the rich eisen show uh
let's get to a little bit at the the
matter at hand right now uh warriors
nation
um not terribly happy with marcus smart
neither is steve kerrs he was diving for
a loose ball yesterday rolled into
steph's
foot that apparently might keep him out
all the way to the playoffs if not maybe
dangerously close
into the playoffs what did you make of
all of that paul pierce you know i
looked at it and i was just like that's
marcus smart i don't think he
intentionally tried to say oh i'm a dive
on the ball at spring steps ankle that's
how marcus smartz plays
we all know that
he plays 100 he gives you 110 he's he's
taking charges diving from loose balls
and i personally i looked at it and i'm
like that's just the nba we are in today
because 10 years ago nobody would even
say nothing about that that's just a
hard play
you know now that we're in an era to
where you can't touch nobody you look at
somebody wrong uh it's a technical it's
a
it's like crazy
like i just thought he was playing hard
it's just unfortunate that
he landed on steph's ankle but if that
was steph
diving and that was marcus smart nobody
would have said that but since that
steph you know one of the guys who's the
face of the league and a crucial part of
what the warriors do
everybody's gonna bring it up it's gonna
be a hot topic
yeah but one of the guys who's upset
about it is from the era of where you
you know
that you're referring to where where
guys could touch one another i mean
steve kerr i mean he got
he got hit he's got his lights punched
out by jordan you know i mean of course
he gonna be upset he lost his mvp how
would you feel
you know what i'm saying you look at
this at this late in the season how
would you feel you lost your most and
one of the most important pieces and and
this is the first time they had all
three of them on the court
the first game
they big three played and then steph go
down
i mean yeah as a coach even though you
come from that area you'll be sick
paul pierce here on the rich eisen show
uh who do you think is right now uh
looking is the favorites to make the nba
finals right now paul
the nba finals man
it's tough out the west
but out of the east man
oh man
i don't want to say i don't want to
sound biased but the celtics are the
best they're playing better than anybody
in the east right now
you know um
you always got to say milwaukee because
they won it last year but i gotta i
gotta ride with my subject boys i think
they've been the best team
uh over the last 25 games
jason tatum has taken this game to
another level
outside of that loss they just had at
home the dallas they've been the best
team in the east and i think they can
ride this all the way to the finals how
about that
you don't think in the western
conference
i i really think it's phoenix is to lose
you know look how they've been playing
even without chris paul you know he's
gonna come back i think phoenix is the
odds-on favorite out west so you don't
uh
i shouldn't say that i i shouldn't say
it this way but i will anyway what the
hell you don't buy embiid and harden
gonna be a two-man game it'll be tough
to stop i don't i don't buy a day i mean
no
it's hard for me to believe that you can
make a mid-season trade and ride a team
to the finals
uh
i think they still have a long way to go
because well playoffs is different you
know all that stuff we see in the
regular season
is smoke and mirrors because now when
you get to the playoffs you play it
against a top-tier team every night each
round the defense gets better
and i just don't see them throwing this
trade together and making it to the
finals this year
and you know where harden's as great as
he's been
then playoffs is different we all know
that and within tough situations he has
to show that he can
he can overcome and be the best player
and he hasn't shown that yet
and we've seen this the potomac too many
years when when they get thick when they
come down to that game six game seven
somehow i don't know why he lay egg i
don't know why but he does as great as
he is and i love hart i mean i think
he's one of he's one of the top 25
players that ever played a game
but
some but in their moments i just i'm not
sure right now what are you doing with
draftkings
what are you doing with draftkings
right now you know i've been i've been
doing a lot of uh
promos for draft kings but there there's
a couple that i just want to run by
everybody's you know behind with the
draftkings crew i want to let everybody
the most important one though is first
of all i want everybody this is me
saying that responsibility that
responsible because this is march
madness and everybody like to you know
put in a bets but
for the most part they're responsible
but i just want for the new users to
know
you know if they bet five dollars they
can get two hundred dollars and free
bets on the college basketball uh money
line uh in this tournament so that's the
big one i want to get out there
okay and at the same time you know like
i like to say their responsibility that
responsible this is march madness
everybody is is excited about college
hoops
and everything is as i am and you know
i'm a kansas guy so
for the jayhawks you know to win it all
did you know that kansas has the longest
active street of making it to the
tournament i didn't know this fact until
a couple days ago
but like i think it's like about 32
straight years they made the tournament
uh this longest active streak so
you know if you're going back back
kansas well i got kansas coming out of
the midwest i have kansas coming out of
the midwest i got i got your jayhawks
coming out of the midwest i just don't
know if they're gonna i'm i mean
this is coach he's got gonzaga don't you
i do not i do not i do not i do not i
have kentucky winning it all
why not why not
why not
they
make fools go
but kansas but kansas isn't kansas isn't
rock chop
kansas isn't let me just make a note of
that okay
hey paul does this mean that you're
pleased to be on this show i get more
paul pierce phone phoners into this
program if not out here in los angeles
you know we're based right by lax very
simple very easy to get give me time you
know you want me to even come to the
studio you know i'm in l.a guys so i do
know let's go yes let's do that we'll
have us we'll have a shabbat show
together how does that sound
oh yeah let's do it
let's do it i'd love it
let's do it on a friday we'll do it on a
friday yeah for sure we're gonna have
some good eat good and talk it up let's
do it paul pierce you're the man thanks
again for calling and thanks for calling
in truly appreciate it
thank you guys i appreciate you guys
that's paul pierce everybody hall of
famer 75th anniversary all-time team
member inglewood's finest right here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here